For generations,
indigenous women, girls and two spirited have endured misogynistic,
degrading, marginalizing and harmful narratives,
systematically denying our worth and withholding protections from us.
This mural serves as a direct and profound act of resistance,
liberation and reclamation of our own narrative.
She dismantles this harmful discourse in a real,
beautiful and unapologetic way.
This is the era of matriarchy where we lead,
we heal and we thrive. As indigenous women,
we are matriarchs, we're activists,
we're leaders, were storytellers,
were mothers and grandmothers and aunties and allies,
were artists and artisans.
Elders were judges and lawyers and teachers and nurses and caregivers,
were students and academics,
were leaders, were chief and councils.
And yes, some of us are even ministers of the Crown.
To our women, girls and two spirit relatives,
I hope that when you see this mural,
you feel it resonate deeply,
both in body and spirit in how truly powerful and beautiful you are.
We are more than what we've been constructed as
and we are more than what is done to our bodies.
Let this mural remind everyone of us,
but especially indigenous women,
girls and two spirited relatives that you are seen,
you are respected,
you are celebrated.
This art is for you
in honor of all that you are and all that you continue to become.
You are loved. Big watch.